ahora que entendemos muy bien cómo
tomarla transpuesta de una matriz
podríamos preguntarnos y no hay razón
para la cual no podamos hacerlo tienes
la transpuesta de un vector de un vector
b que vamos a pensar es el vector de uno
de dos hasta hasta de n así que bien
tienes este vector transpuesto quien
sería de transpuesto pues podemos pensar
en este vector b como una matriz de n
por uno tiene en entradas y una columna
así que b transpuesta sería una matriz
de uno por n y sería simplemente tomar
esta columna y convertirla en un riñón
así que sería la matriz o el vector de
uno de dos hasta
y en este sentido en este sentido de
hecho ya lo he hecho lo había hecho
antes podría definir una matriz a como
la matriz cuyos renglones son algún
vector a1 transpuesto un vector a 2
transpuesto y así así hasta un vector a
m transpuesto y entonces podría hablar
de los renglones de la matriz a pero
bueno no quiero distraerme mucho ya que
tengo esto que más puedo hacer con estos
vectores pues por ejemplo podría pensar
en otro vector w vamos a pensar en un
vector w
digamos dado por www hasta
wv en este es otro vector de rn ok
y podría en principio tomar el producto
interior el producto punto debe con w
quien sería el producto punto w pues por
definición simplemente sería de 1 por w
1 más de 2 por w 2 y así así continuar
sumando estas cosas hasta de n por w en
la definición del producto punto
simplemente es multiplicar las entradas
correspondientes e irla sumando
ok pero como se relaciona esto con esto
que tenemos acá arriba de las trans
puestas pues si yo anotó esto como o más
bien si considero el producto de b
transpuesto que quien sería haber
transpuesto sería el vector de 1 b 2
sería la matriz perdón la matriz b1 b2
hasta
en la tengo acá arriba
si estaré aquí y la podría multiplicar
por vamos a usar otro color vamos a usar
azul
no podría multiplicar por la matriz www
hasta w m
esto de aquí es sencillamente el vector
w
pues aquí tengo un producto
tengo un producto de una matriz de 1 por
n con una matriz de n por 1 así que como
coinciden el número de columnas en esta
matriz / transpuesta con el número de
renglones en w este producto está bien
definido y quién es pues sería una
matriz de uno por uno sería una matriz
de uno por uno y sería la matriz de uno
por doble uno
más de dos por w dos más continúa
sumando hasta que llegó a b n por w n
así que tengo esta matriz pero si
ustedes se fijan estas dos cosas
estas dos cosas realmente son lo mismo
la única diferencia es que esta es una
matriz pero puedo hacer esta
identificación y pensar en estas dos
cosas como el mismo objeto de ese modo
si hago esta identificación de las
matrices de uno por uno con simplemente
números reales bueno matrices de uno por
uno con entradas reales con números
reales entonces podría decir podría
decir que
el resultado de tomar ave y hacerle
producto interior con w que
incidentalmente sería lo mismo sería
exactamente lo mismo que w producto
puntocom de estas dos cosas son iguales
y esto lo puedo pensar como simplemente
el resultado de multiplicar a la matriz
be transpuesta por la matriz w así que
hay un modo de relacionar el producto
punto de vectores con el producto de la
matriz transpuesta de un vector con el
otro vector pensados como matrices así
que aquí tenemos un resultado bastante
bonito
veamos qué más puedo hacer con las trans
puestas bien pues qué pasa si ahora
tengo por ejemplo una matriz anna que es
una matriz de m por n y tengo un vector
x tengo un vector x vamos a pensar que x
es un miembro d
un miembro de r
y entonces puedo pensar a x como una
matriz de n por 1 así que esto digamos
que me da un vector zeta y qué forma va
a tener zeta pues zeta
z es el resultado de multiplicar estas
dos matrices estoy pensando al vector x
como una matriz de n por 1 entonces el
resultado tendría dimensiones estas dos
se cancelan y tendría m renglones y una
columna así que zeta ceta se vería algo
así z 1 z 2 hasta
hasta z m
ahí estaría z así que z puedo pensar a z
qué es lo mismo
qué es lo mismo que el resultado
multiplicar a x por la matriz a como un
elemento de r m perfecto pero entonces
si tengo un elemento de rm y yo tengo
otro vector nrm digamos que también está
en r m entonces tendría sentido tendría
bastante bastante sentido si ahora me
preocupo por qué pasa si yo hago el
producto interior de a por x
que recuerden es receta que estén rm y
le hago producto interior producto punto
con quien sería esto pues a ver veamos
mi definición bajo esta identificación
que hicimos de vectores con matrices
y bueno vectores con matrices de n x 1
y también con matrices de uno por uno
con números reales esto sería lo mismo
que
a x x transpuesta por el vector y como
producto de matrices pero nosotros
sabemos que hace creo que dos o tres
vídeos que si tenemos la traspuesta del
producto de las matrices a y b esto es
lo mismo que la transporta y ve por la
transporta de a así que transponga e
invierte el orden ok entonces tienes
esto pues esto de aquí sencillamente se
reduciría a
x transpuesta x a transpuesta eso sería
el primer caso y eso lo voy a
multiplicar x
x
y el vector
ahora yo sé también lo vimos hace ya
varios vídeos que el producto de
matrices es asociativo no importa como
ponga los paréntesis así que esto
también lo podría escribir como
x transpuesta x
a transpuesta por el vector que
recuerden estoy identificando a los
vectores a un vector en este caso en r m
con una matriz de m por 1 y eso es lo
que me permite tomar transpuestas y
tratar esto como el producto de matrices
muy bien pero ahora quien esa
transpuesta pues la transpuesta es
alguna matriz a era de m por n así que a
transpuesta es alguna matriz de n por m
y ya es un vector en r m así que este
producto está bien definido x déjenme
voy anotando las dimensiones a
transpuesta es de n por m
y es un vector de rm y es un vector de r
m así que lo puedo pensar como una
matriz de gm por 1 así que todo esto de
aquí
toda esta matriz sería una matriz de
dimensiones se cancelan las emes y me
queda n por 1 así que esto
esto lo puedo pensar como miembro de rn
que está perfecto porque x pertenecía a
rn x pertenecía a irene entonces
utilizando esta definición de acá arriba
esta identificación x transpuesta por
esta cosa es lo mismo así que déjenme lo
pongo acá esto es lo mismo
x el vector x producto interior con el
vector a transpuesta por d
tengo que el resultado de tomar el
producto interior de a por x con un
vector de es igual a
el vector x producto interior o producto
puntocom a transpuesta por d este
resultado es bastante útil y bastante
importante más adelante lo vamos a ver
ok entonces déjenme anoto todas las
casas que hicimos en este vídeo
descubrimos dos cosas muy importantes la
primera es que ve producto punto con w
lo puedo pensar como
de transpuesta por w pensándolo como el
producto de matrices y asumo que todo
esto tienen las dimensiones adecuadas
para que esto esté bien definido y el
otro resultado importante que
descubrimos es que qué color uso
amarillo
es que
a por el vector x producto punto con un
vector de es lo mismo que x producto
punto con a transpuesta por el vector y
este resultado es más bien este par de
resultados va a ser bastante útil en el
futuro